you're painting a fantasy and the ha you
see it as a fantasy I mean I think the
fantasy is using the system to think
that it's going to bend to our will my
name is Derek Broz I'm 33 from Houston
Texas I'm a journalist and activist my
name is Caleb I'm originally from the
Bay Area but I just moved out and I am
21 years old
I'm Andrew I am 27 years old I'm from
Skandia Minnesota and I'm a documentary
filmmaker I am - Lisa Raye I'm 42 and
I'm a senior analyst for a utility my
name is Karissa I'm 21 and I'm a student
my name is Renata I'm 24 I'm from
Pennsylvania and I work for a software
company
well I believe my vote matters because
I'm a woman and first it was denied for
us and now I have the opportunity to use
my voice but in addition I'm able to use
my voice as a black woman excuse me
emotional about that considering though
we were citizens black people long time
ago we weren't given really the right or
we were denied access ability to go to
the voting polls until I feel like it is
my opportunity to go ahead and speak I
have the ability to vote I have the
privilege to vote so I will do so and
like growing up like my older sister
wasn't able to vote until like a couple
years ago because she's autistic and
since it's the whole guardianship thing
and it was actually until a couple years
ago that people under guardianship were
able to vote and also because of the
undocumented people that are around me
and my family all the formerly
incarcerated people that are
disproportionately affecting you know
black people I think it's always
important to vote not for myself but for
them I come from Minnesota and I think
it's a very civically involved state I
always saw you
everybody kind of voted and when I was
going into college I was a part of this
campaign called the vote no campaign
which was to turn down a constitutional
amendment which would have made it
illegal for gay people to get married
and I am gay and so I got involved in
that campaign to to try to prevent it
from happening and we went from a very
low approval rate of same-sex marriage
in Minnesota to in just less than a year
a very large approval rate and we ended
up defeating that constitutional
amendment and eventually became one of
the states that that legalized same-sex
marriage I'm part Seminole well and our
ancestry the same thing had been denied
different I hesitate to call them rights
because I don't think things that the
government gives you our rights are more
like privileges you
so I I don't really know if I would call
it that but I definitely understand them
denying us certain privileges in the
past and how now that we have those
privileges sometimes we feel inclined
like well my ancestors didn't get to do
this so I need to do this but I still
hesitate to say that my vote matters now
there are some instances like for
example you were talking about gay
marriage and I think maybe on a local
level we could see the impact of our
actions now I think it's become
increasingly clear that whether you're
talking about the electoral college or
voting machines being hacked or you know
not even getting into philosophical side
of things that your vote really doesn't
matter at the end of the day there's a
small group of people who decide what
goes understand your point especially
with the history part however I also
feel though that it's an informed
decision that I'm making and of course
it's more impactful locally and because
of that because of my community and
where I live and all the changes that
occur it's important for me to to have
that voice even if there's an off chance
that it may not really be effective it's
my right to use that voice and I'm sure
you can understand that I think my vote
does matter to an extent where it shows
that I agree what's happening
politically and since I do disagree with
what's going on politically and I don't
believe that this country has a true
democracy that's where I think my vote
doesn't matter at that point for me I'm
more of a moderate but I do lean a
little bit conservative but as from
being in California you know the votes
are gonna be towards more Democratic
votes
personally I don't think my vote
wouldn't matter you know when I'm voting
for the primary the way I see it is that
I vote every single day I vote with my
actions I'm very involved in my
community what drives me crazy I guess
is just that every two to four years
people all of a sudden pop up and act
like they know what's going on around
the country just because the TV or the
Internet's telling them oh it's that
time to pay attention again and so they
get ready to you know and then you get
to the point where some people are
shaming those who choose not to
participate you know so you know I just
I guess just for me I want to encourage
more people to vote like with their very
being not just like right on that slip
of paper I press that button and like
okay that's it I'll worry about it again
in two years four years whatever
[Music]
yeah I mean I'm proud to be American I
really am there's a lot of opportunities
that this country has given me I don't
necessarily agree what's happening in
the government I don't necessarily agree
with the way of life here but I'm happy
to be from here and I'll always be proud
I'd moved to Brazil to finish my degree
and when I was living there I kind of
had to make the decision whether I
wanted to move back to the United States
or not the reason why I was thinking
about staying in Brazil was why I wasn't
happy with some of the things going on
in the United States the politics the
health care system all of these things
were just stacking up and I was thinking
how that country's going to [ __ ] but I
realized well I can either be a part of
the solution of making it better or I
can just give up and run away but I
chose to come back here and I've been
living here for five years though I am
glad to be here in America when I think
of patriotic I think of I believe in
everything that the country stands for
you know how we operate and I'm just
gonna be honest with you I don't it's
two million justices in today's society
I'm a bit embarrassed to say I'm an
American
that's the lesser of two evils that's
exactly why does it have to be two evils
yeah exactly
why not liable or why not look to other
parties why party systems
I don't follow under neither under my
religion not one politician has ever
understood what it's like to be a Muslim
nothing is being nothing's being pushed
from ijen and it won't be it will not be
and I think the the whole system the way
it's set up it's just it's always has an
agenda for a certain type of people and
it's always gonna be for that certain
type of people it's a propaganda to get
people the masses of people to believe
that we have a voice and to believe that
we have democracy when we really do not
but you don't agree that they were the
right candidate I don't know so I don't
have a voice I'd wear this country's go
well the way I understand it works
though is they got there somehow they
got there so like we're kind of even
when somebody like Bernie Sanders tries
to say hey we're gonna use all our
grassroots delegates and we're gonna
challenge the system using their own
rules well then they just change the
rules I guess that's why I feel like we
should vote though especially right now
for the primaries it's like I don't
think we should give up it sounds like
you guys giving up it's just approaching
it in a different way to me was when I
say though as an activist aren't you
trying to promote change through your
action but through people's minds not
through the political system well for me
I didn't vote for either two candidates
I wanted one Gen John Kasich to win the
Republican Party but he didn't and then
also Gary Johnson as an independent but
personally I didn't want to vote
independent because just my community
members seeing on social media don't
vote independent or you're gonna let
Trump win I can't please both sides cuz
it's so far left or far right and I'm
just like what do I do you know and I
think I got to the point where I got
frustrated where it's just like you know
what I'm just not gonna vote I just feel
that our current system is not inclusive
of everyone's thoughts and ideas we
create a binary we force people to
choose one thing or the other and that
exists like in all aspects of you know
being a person and participating in you
know politics like there's so many
different types of people there's so
many like different types of you know
thoughts that they have could be
beneficial and I think we should
probably start existing outside of that
yeah I think it's the bottom voice
that's you know small I think that we're
the bottom and so we start with the
change change starts with us when we
look in the mirror and how we see
ourselves and how we see other people I
believe that's where it starts
absolutely you know I think that really
the the smallest minority we talk about
a lot of minorities but the smallest
minority that is always under threat is
the individual you know those
individuals can be gay can be black you
like me Muslim but it's the individual
individual rights pertaining to a number
of different issues at the end of the
day I think that you know you Minnesota
would have got a lot sooner to gay
marriage and approve of that if the
government just got the heck out of the
way and let free people do whatever they
want and get married as they please and
you know vote when they please and you
know come just get the heck out of the
way in all sorts of arenas and let
people organize their affairs you know
men women whatever color whatever
religion I get that but that's not an
option
I think like you're you you're painting
a fantasy and you see it as a fantasy I
mean I think the fantasy is using a
system to think that it's gonna bend to
our will I mean that wasn't an option
that's not a choice it's like you could
say the same thing about women's rights
african-american rights and but people
worked together to change that and
that's what I'm saying I think that's
where the divide is is like right now
I'm saying we should work together to
have a positive impact on the
absolutely I'm with you I just won't
follow you into the ballot box consider
the system that we are in today and how
you can make the change today whether
you feel that it is not impactful your
vote for me matters your vote locally
matters it'll change something in
someone's community so consider for me I
want you to consider the thought that
someone else somewhere else does not
have the same opportunity to go in and
be heard in the way that they choose for
me I'm always gonna have a lot of
respect for people who I decide not to
vote because they don't believe it
system works
I agree to that to a certain extent but
I believe that local voting is always
the most important thing like voting in
your community has always been a part of
forming that community I think for now
on it's just more like I hope that there
are people who won't be too far right
too far left and that we could all just
kind of like chill out and that I could
like you know just vote because it's my
opinion and mine yes and that I hope
that no one belittles me for that
opinion that I might have it might not
be popular or it might not be trendy on
social media but that will be just
accept it and that I don't need it to
Swit like take one side or the other
side at the end of the day people can do
whatever they want and they can keep a
private to themselves as well and if you
continue doing the same things that
you're doing nothing's gonna change
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys Jason from jublee here thank
you so much for watching another episode
of middle ground as always we love
hearing from you guys and we'd love to
hear thoughts in the comments below let
us know if there's something that you
disagreed with or agreed with real of
seeing that discussion and creating this
radical empathy as always make sure you
click to subscribe to more videos from
Jubilee make sure to hit the bell for
notifications click here to watch more
videos and we'll see you as next time
live greater